you're gonna see me get into a bunch of
carnival games like darts pool hockey
and basketball you're gonna see me do a
podcast with Aubree and then most
importantly you're gonna see me rock
this theater in a Q&A session for the
ages
[Music]
you got your prospective be happy don't
you want to be happy that really stopped
me dead in my tracks and I'm gonna tell
you why I'm obsessed with perspective
like I genuinely believe you find what
you're looking for if you're looking for
bad right now it's a piece of cake if
you're looking for good right now it's a
piece of cake I'm just asking you what
the [ __ ] are you looking for
[Music]
[Music]
no I know I [ __ ] had a pleasure to
meet you I kicked down some see this
warning thank you bro that's crazy
what's your name Michelle Phoebe she
works for a Remax it let me hit let's
let's surprise her Michelle the hole you
want me to FaceTime runner Michelle yeah
Michelle this timing is everything
everything should we blow no thanks yeah
I got you appreciate it you know don't
tell him Shh
you know we're doing it
[Music]
what do you what would you like to
happen so come a couple a couple things
you'll like this like it kind of like
working out or like eating properly like
ironically ironically not a lot changes
it just becomes you know you're getting
the results of putting out the work
literally you're one day away from a
video or a piece of content really
changing the outcome of the growth but
the reality is even if you'll have
something go bananas the reality is that
one two three pieces of content a day
keeps putting another block another
block another block right you know like
the way you get a real muscular body is
by putting to work in a gym every single
day there is no shortcut so let me ask
you this how often are you posting on
Instagram so to me one of things to just
debate is is it for right like is it
actually just for because the reality is
for me it's for by the way that's my
number and you know I always say about
should be five you know like you know so
that's me as one place where to answer a
question directly you can do you can get
bigger by putting out more content the
other question comes what other things
we putting out so where are you
obviously really on Instagram where are
you when it comes to LinkedIn or Twitter
or podcast do that nature where you on
that yeah you appreciate this know I was
born in Russia right and grew up in a
you know household with two parents that
live their entire life in Russia and
like the last thing you're doin
communism is share so I understand the
concept of even for me like it was a
process as an extrovert you know like it
was process but the reality is you're
doing it right like what's cool about
you for me and what you're talking right
now is you know but um for president I
think life with the stuff we don't share
is normally but people say when they're
not doing anything the fact that you're
already doing now just chipping away
daily like listen you need to be doing
Twitter I'm telling you what your face
it's gonna work for you and your style
of content like I honestly think you
should putting out content on LinkedIn
about one thing specifically how to be
successful when people be enter the
world from prison and how companies can
be using those in that level of
diversity is actually a remarkable
advantage if it's manifested properly
right so I think there's places that you
have permission to go to that I can't go
to you know
I can't from a first-party point of view
talk about what it's like of what my
thoughts are I don't the context of that
was happening that system so they
answered your question is more four
times dating strip and Twitter and I
know you didn't grow up using it but you
figured out how to use Instagram you're
gonna figure out how to use Twitter
you're gonna figure out how to post on
LinkedIn that's just real that's who you
are you you've already proved it
sup bro how're you doing - well good
good to see you good to see - what's
going down
not too much come on in everybody what
else going on not too much we got some
caramel games set up we're gonna go
around and [ __ ] around yeah it's a nice
knock cool balls around and place your
place sauce looks all sake game I'm
ready
I don't think I [ __ ] throwing a dart
and like [ __ ] that's real good for the
first start I thrown in [ __ ] 600
years
oh god those first two were [ __ ]
legit I'm very happy with that
all right one zero that's good ups
that's good up high like what this is ed
it yep
one one one run the road team puts one
up on the board
oh sure we'll play this is it two and
three okay all right understood mmm-hmm
I get it okay that might be enough okay
hit there's room there's a lot of room
I am the Tuck oh I am the target
schmuck I think you won dude oh dude
that's the one it is isn't it busted
water let's go let's go let's go
[Music]
well there we go that was just a
practice shot get in there
mm nice oh very good
god I'm a [ __ ] played pool ever
oh that [ __ ] hurt
[Music]
oh [ __ ] you and miss the conference nice
shot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Jeffrey breakout Lucille
[Laughter]
[Applause]
whoo let's go
be careful Nick do [ __ ] get a
Minnesota Fats this [ __ ] it's gonna be
really bad for your birth that's gonna
be really bad for your brand Nick do did
you see that you're slightly impressed
with that right
mmm I just have a good hand-eye
coordination so it makes me dangerous at
all times that's what happened in darts
that's what it is this is a tough one
good [ __ ] good [ __ ] ops you're worried
there for a second you needed that you
were [ __ ] up - all right all right
the family's super pumped the collective
sigh in this room was like thank God
we're not going out of business
holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ] cool I don't
even know what what is this game sauce
so it's real hot okay I'm in deep [ __ ]
here based on like the idea of a saucer
pass okay so you don't even know what
the [ __ ] that is okay if you gotta get
it in there and then if you get in the
little goal it's three points if you get
it in the big net so it's three points
in here at one point yeah and you can't
bounce it in it has to either hip in yep
okay or go straight in it okay and so
the sauce the key is you got to roll it
across the you gotta roll it from the
bottom of the stick across like that do
you have to do that or is that like a
good way to get in the air where to get
it and I understand it's to like roll it
that one pointer okay 11 15 15 all right
let's go
understood all right that hit the ground
no soft
that's no sausage [ __ ] all right at one
point all right all right well no one
this seriously that was too good for the
first three shots
I feel confident confident three nothing
you know it's a big lead it's a big lead
and sauce
that was big that was the mayor ups that
was the opening I needed that goalposts
got me high [ __ ] three-pointer that
[ __ ] hurt I think you'd have to go
exact that's what I never playing sauce
1:07 sounds right actually sounds right
in the middle o in the middle yeah yeah
let's go
I love sauce seven one seven one let's
go that was huge
oh [ __ ] you're so sold in though it's
just a foregone conclusion I gotta get
my [ __ ] together here's the problem
right now with us playing sauce I'm
gonna be here for next [ __ ] four
hours practicing sauce
[Music]
let's go
things are getting interesting that's a
lot of momentum all the post
I love the [ __ ] pose poses been my
friend right in the [ __ ] middle ah
[Music]
nope ground right in the [ __ ] middle
right in the middle Oh hanging out for
dear life what's at fourteen nine nine
Oh God one more give me one last chance
I've nine I can three it into it I got
it give me one last prayer yes
intimidating not trying to
böck
just rip it of [ __ ] sauce right in
the [ __ ] middle damage this is such a
good idea I'm gonna start bringing
people to vaynermedia to play games that
I play all the time and the other
person's never played such a good idea
alright let's go shoot hoops god I
haven't good on since the uh oh you
weren't there
did you hear about that holy [ __ ]
[Applause]
Ivan Ivan played since I haven't shot a
basketball in like forever
[Music]
he sucks
Oh
[Music]
sounds good
you gotta use everything you got need
all these different variables
[Applause]
No
no infield
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I came out so confident nice is good see
you provide my guys that's awesome this
is sweet all my fans are graces you know
usually when I go on podcast for things
that nature I'm like trying to answer
the questions I'm thinking I've already
done it once here I'm listening so I'm
thinking of new things to say that
really stopped me dead in my tracks and
I'm gonna tell you why I'm obsessed with
perspective like I genuinely believe you
find what you're looking for
if you are looking for bad right now
it's a piece of cake if you're looking
for good right now it's a piece of cake
I'm just asking you what the [ __ ] are
you looking for like please just a very
simple question like and by the way I I
hate in a lot of ways I hate the way I
talk because it's super simple and I'm
sitting right now thinking about the kid
who's listening to this and she or he is
in a room right now earpods in listening
to this and they're miserable because
their dad's an alcoholic or their moms
they're like real [ __ ] you know like
tough stuff and they're like ah it's so
slick [ __ ] you it's not that simple yet
it is like you know one thing I don't do
well is talk about my problems it which
manifests in many ways it manifests in
being taken for granted in my real life
and in my collective life by outward
life now I got [ __ ] problems lots of
problems real ones I grew up with lots
of this stuff like lots and lots of lots
of stuff I just am not capable of going
into it
like I don't I don't get going like I
can't get there and so one of the things
that I you know that I try to remind
kids and like take me out of the
equation like
even use me when I'm saying these things
to breed if you know of one person that
has ever gotten to a happy place that
dealt with your circumstance there is a
blueprint the end it there have been
people Nightrain Lane legendary football
player was thrown in a dumpster the
second he was born went on to be one of
the great football players of all time
dated every actress in the game was red
foxes bodyguard iconic gentleman
dumpster like like there's all sorts of
circumstances and you know who else
dumpsters I apologize
you know what's dumpsters kids to have
too much you want to talk about who I'm
actually getting hit up by it's not the
kid in the hood that saw me with you
know gonna and they think I'm cool now
they're like how do I get other it's
kids that have our trust fund babies who
are sick listen and I know this I never
judge somebody that comes from a shitty
circumstance I'm a cheerleader I'm an
underdog guy right I care that I see I I
meet you and we're friends and then like
we're at a dinner party and my friend
comes home just you know that is right
like that's the grandson of Buchan
Howard Hughes I immediately judge that
person nothing that person never
achieves I'll give credit to that's me
that's actually how I see the world
I will not fully give credit to my own
children because of that reason I really
I'm being very transparent here I would
much rather in a world of the internet
where the internet doesn't care who you
are I would much rather in 2019 come
from too little then come from too much
not in 1984 cuz there was no internet
and all those relationships and all that
money really mattered but I believe that
we're living in a very funny time we're
Klout reputation work ethic a lot of
different things are starting to be put
on pedestals not just money and earning
your keep and who you are and what
you're giving to the world and I think
we're living in a very interesting
transition whatever you have it changes
your start position and that can be
overwhelming right it's all about what
you do with what you have from way way
and by the way it's all perspective
right for me as somebody who take so
much pride in the process I wouldn't
have wanted to start on third and a half
base somebody else's sin right now's
like I'm pretty cool with it
Bertie pump pops made fifty Pino and
that's fine by the weight but here's
where it's really fun here's where it
gets super like interesting or not and
guess what
who the [ __ ] are all the busts you're on
third and a half piece and you end up on
second half base and what you gonna do
and this is actually the punchline
I want like actually somebody's
listening right now if you're somebody
who's like 50 60 70 and you started in
third and half base and ended on second
and half base but you're pumped is
[ __ ] happy for real please email me
I'm really like I just want to know that
insight because I actually think it's
the reverse of me what happens me I
think it's similar to me which is what
actually happens when you can calibrate
judgment I believe one of the biggest
reasons that I'm one of the forefront
basis of all this is because I can
handle the judgment too much hate I have
there's a video right now of a young
woman doing a motivational speech she
crushed it it's going a little viral on
Twitter I'm getting destroyed by the
comments they're like yeah [ __ ] that
Gary Vee guy I know that - you're
freaking making fun of that hurts and
most people are folding their chairs
when they get judged like that I'm not
because I know every one of those people
who said that I've never met me I can
handle judgment if you don't know me if
Caleb and Nick do thought it was a
[ __ ] then I would have a real
problem well then it's a true reflection
but you know it's not the truest like
are we elves are the truest mirror of
ourselves if we actually are fair and we
actually look without the biases that we
all bring then we're the only ones I
mean bode miller was someone who talks
oh yeah he was like if someone pumps
your tires they don't know you if they
congratulate you on that like he would
get congratulated on finishing a race
and he didn't like the race he couldn't
take that he's like well I didn't
[ __ ] ski at my best and he would ski
is best sometimes crash or not finished
well and everybody like all sorry man
you'd be like [ __ ] you man like I
[ __ ] skied my best no no I mean man
honestly like that just got me fired up
about Bodhi I'm the same way man like
like it's unbelievable how I just I do
not take the accolades and I do not take
the hate I'm just [ __ ] in the middle
I'm in my own head it's really a
reflection Hussain
I'll be honest I appreciate you
appreciate this it doesn't even go that
far bro honestly I've got your pods in
24/7 can your [ __ ] from my mom to a
stranger just don't hear it I don't know
what else to tell you I'm in a very
[ __ ] place a very interesting place on
this you know what it's driven by
empathy I know they don't know me they
don't know me they they just can't
[ __ ] begin to know me like I hate
Scottie Pippen
I don't know Scottie Pippen so I
understand it I [ __ ] hate Scottie
Pippen I despise Tom Brady and I
actually know a lot of people that no
man sounds like is a fairly solid dude I
still [ __ ] hate them and so like if
I'm willing to do that then everyone's
willing to do that and that's permission
and that's it and so like but but I
think judgment is on tilt judgment is
like [ __ ] I'm telling you man like
that's all we're doing now people are
just [ __ ] hot taking each other 24/7
365 casting judgment scale judgment is
on tilt judgment is as momentum judgment
is the is the is the undertone right now
and honestly I want to push so against
it or calibrate it you know like I'm
just I've lost so much momentum in
judging somebody you can't imagine the
last five years everybody does it it's a
human trait but like mine doesn't get
going anymore
like I'm just like I don't know anything
about anybody
that was awesome I think people gonna
really enjoy that [ __ ] yeah that was a
good one
love it
[Music]
what's that
lots of the same I think I'll probably
sound like thing no you know what spring
I actually value just think about me I
know I look like six or seven it might
be just general the real question will
be coming but will I ever take a step
off
that's just a period of time before I
step behind like that's what I'm asking
me I'm in such a swirl constant motion
like will I want to or I need to
literally just think not like a ticket
gap you're taking gear off feel like you
know it's quite a challenge to like I'm
macro stimulated you know like super
bathroom you can't walk off the stage
and it's like edits and honestly it's
Superman and by the way or just have a
nice podcast session here they feel good
about it like that could get like I'm
just in in perpetual motion and you know
you always you know think about this
right
like just we have to shake I'm like it's
like like I'm just I guess what I said
that interviews the truth it's super
good now I'm not gonna over stress it
and it's like I don't you know I don't
know either either I'm doing a cliche
thing where you don't recognize that you
crack or what it's great it's just every
bank robber movie ever
you know it's like they're gonna get one
more I look mad they're pretty confident
that I don't crack in like a crazy desk
I think my version of that will be like
[ __ ] I'm really genuinely unhappy
professionally for the first time in my
career let me spend the next 12 to 18
months to unwind my responsibilities
will allow me to mix it up
[Music]
[Music]
this song this song got a second wave of
like life when I was in high school it's
probably ready for another one it might
be alright
meatloaf yeah make sense I highly
recommend you don't put it in part of
the blog you're gonna get destroyed even
worse my visual of it is when he was a
coach I guess Idol I judge it's Miss
America a chance to add one more
contestant as the 16th semifinalist so
which I would never forget Carly this is
5 years old
hello yeah hey Gary to them again
look we're seriously considering you
know we're trying to expand a little bit
and looking for somebody in social like
would you consider judging Miss America
let me think about it
yeah they're just really like a fun
thing it was especially fun for me
because when we first when we lived in
Edison like one of the most American
things for me is when we made it is when
we moved to the suburbs in Edison and
one of the best things we did with my
mom me and my sister for like like from
1982 to 1988 was like award shows it was
a big thing they could all get in my
mom's bed and we would watch or we try
to guess like award shows like any of
them the Grammys the totally and then
like and things like Miss America so
like that's why it was so fun for me
Miss America 1984 through 1988 laying in
my mom's bed with my sister and watching
that competition and trying to guess who
won is a core early American story to my
heart so I'm here because I'm selfish
because it meant something to me growing
up and I thought it would mean a lot
from me and my family my sister mom
specifically that I'm here I was correct
they're both very emotional excited and
I'm happy to do that I always think in
terms of like when I do something when I
call my mom what does she think
you know what does she think of like
look how far we've come right you know
yeah that's why the that's why you got
to beat my face computer so I'll use it
if that's heavy for me the speaker was
crazy but this is unreal smells like a
college dorm room right so we're just
about to get going look at this
beautiful theater theater Caleb look at
just like this old school [ __ ] that I
like so much
anyway you know thousand people in the
theater in Austin Texas I have a very
funny feeling I'm about to go completely
off the [ __ ] rocker because the
energy of more people always gets moved
to a totally different place so super
psyched and then from here Russian very
quickly as you guys know cuz you watch a
lot of my content I don't tend to go
private but I gotta get a private place
I gonna be in Nashville tomorrow morning
right early bright and early a keynote
in Nashville I got a run home because
tomorrow's make third one of my favorite
days of the year my mom's birthday so
I'm gonna rush home give love there and
get into the weekend and so it's been a
pretty intense the intense [ __ ] week
from even for me like fly to San
Francisco red-eye back go right into
work all day 11:15 and wake up at 3 a.m.
private flight to Ohio with a client 3
at 3:30 in the morning which is the
earliest flight I've ever taken land
quickly catch a play from here or two
from Ohio Columbus to here in Austin now
rolling hardcore this home a land in
Nashville tonight at midnight go at 7:00
a.m. like it's [ __ ] perpetual [ __ ]
motion when you're in it when you're one
with your thing it sounds intense coming
out of my mouth but it's easier than
sitting through first class science
what up what up hey Gary this is my
first time coming but I'm a high school
high school student so I'm gonna
graduate in June but I always have a
plan to do but my parents they don't
want me like to give myself a chance and
don't first want me to go to college and
I try and ask them for time like to do
something mm-hmm but they said like they
want me like they want to see the result
of what I'm doing quickly and they
always like forcing me to go to college
and and stop and they said like if I'd
really want to do my own thing they want
me to go to college and at the same time
work on my plan okay and at the same
time also wanted me to help them with
their business and I said I couldn't do
that so what would be like advice you
would give like just you should go do
your own thing but like my surrounding
they just like so forcing me to do what
they wanted me to do instead but they're
not in charge they're only in charge if
you're using their home and their money
okay and plus my mom she was like she
said that I am disappointed her because
of my choice of course because she's
using psychological pressure for you to
do what she wants
the only thing you have to figure out is
that they have any leverage the only
leverage they have is money shelter and
psychological warfare what's that I'm
living with them so well if you're gonna
want to go do your own thing you're
gonna have to move and you're not gonna
have to you get like here's my big thing
with kids like as you can tell I'm very
Pro you but if you're gonna go do this
thing that's disappointing them then you
can't take from them either because then
you're being spoiled so if you feel so
passionate about this thing that you
want to go do go do it but don't expect
them to support it because they don't
believe in it so go stick it in their
face right let me tell you one thing
about parents and this is very common
they may be upset now but if you go and
pull this off
they will not be disappointed and more
importantly if you go and try this deep
down one day they'll tell you secretly
that they're not disappointed you're
welcome
[Applause]
Thank You
length I'll leave with this like we've
gone very high-level here tonight let me
go very tactical LinkedIn right this
minute is acting the same exact way that
Facebook in two thousand nine ten and
eleven was working you could post about
anything not just business stuff and the
organic reach is ridiculous
I highly recommend that every single
person tomorrow puts their first post on
LinkedIn in video or written form I
think you will be astonished by what
happens I love you back yes let's go
fast it's not gonna sit don't tell
anybody
I'm trying to see how nice I gotta go
him to miss his [ __ ] flight positive
missus [ __ ] flight Oh keep it thank
you so much thank you
thanks for coming thank you for coming
thank you for coming
it's get them sink thank you for coming
see you thank you thank you bye guys
I gotta go catch my flight I Love You
Man thank you thank you so much
Airport yeah I can walk a little bit if
like this is Gerardo yeah let's
I tell you in LA I guess
it's still possible but how do I just
keep [ __ ] emailing I promise you we
don't wanna keep doing please
whose birthday let's go let's do it
thank you
yeah I got so far buddy yo so he's very
much watching Thank You Caleb beets real
quick real quick I'm really gonna miss
this place fellas I will Eddy alright
one two
I'm about that I'm about that
I think something I've been talking
about for six months which is if you got
rid of the like everybody be a much
better [ __ ] sure yeah and this is
somebody gets a lot of likes but [ __ ] it
it's real it's real thank you
I know all right actually met you
downtown and uh what's up I got a really
really go okay it'll really really go
hey good to see you again take care
everyone done I love your deal yeah all
right octave Asheville straight up like
if you're watching this it would mean so
much to me if you hit the bell and to
subscribe it be part of this thank you
[Music]
[Music]